docteur nicolas chadi pédiatre au centre
hospitalier universitaire sainte-justine
bonsoir nivelles boudreau président de
la commission scolaire de la
pointe-de-l'île
bonsoir vous êtes dans nos studios à
montréal alors bonsoir à vous deux je
commence avec vous docteur chadi est ce
que c'est une bonne idée d'après vous
que de repousser l'heure du début des
classes c'est une excellente idée en
fait on sait que nos jeunes n'ont pas
assez de sommeil puis il ya quelque
chose qui se passe à l'adolescence ou en
fait les jeunes oui secousses plus tard
pour des raisons sociales mais leur
système leur horloge du sommeil interne
fait en sorte que c'est plus difficile
d'avoir du sommeil en début de soirée et
qu'une motion comme ça pourrait vraiment
permettre d'avoir plus de sommeil et en
tout et partout
monsieur boudreau alors la question
simple à vous êtes responsable d'une
commission scolaire il ya des écoles qui
commence à 7h40 7h45
cet ancien cas pourquoi on ne donne pas
une lime et à 8 à 8 heures un peu ce que
je peux vous expliquer par rapport à
l'organisation scolaire c'est que la
plage horaire pour les écoles du
primaire va de 7h45 pour le début des
classes jusqu'à 8h45 dans qui a des
enfants qui commencent plus tard que
huit heures au niveau secondaire ça peut
aller de 8h10 le matin jusqu'à 9h30
alors donc au niveau de l'entrée audit
du début des classes ça respecte grosso
modo un peu les paramètres que qui
viennent d'être annoncées pour la
californie là évidemment ou le bas
peuvent laisser davantage c'est à cause
du transport scolaire dans notre
commission scolaire en moyenne les
élèves qui prennent le bus scolaire vont
faire 30 minutes de transport dans
certains cas ça peut aller jusqu'à 60
minutes pour les parents qui font le
choix d'inscrire leur enfant qui est à
l'extérieur de leur quartier donc c'est
là où les enfants doivent se lever
beaucoup plus tôt c'est en raison du
transport scolaire bon et de faire ch a
dit qu'est ce qui arrive quand un enfant
ne dort pas s'il ya beaucoup de parents
que je les entends déjà nous grille on
le sait ça dérègle leur humeur en trop
mais à moyen
et à long terme que ce carré il ya une
multitude d'impact sur la santé on sait
qu'un déficit de sommeil durant
l'enfance l'adolescence à peut avoir un
impact direct sur le développement du
cerveau a évidemment des conséquences au
niveau de la santé mentale ça peut aussi
avoir une des conséquences sur la pythie
sur la motivation on le sait ça a des
conséquences directes sur les résultats
scolaires donc vraiment c'est les
ramifications qui sont très larges à
courre est évidemment à moyen terme
surtout si on parle du du rendement de
la réussite scolaire de même aussi un
risque augmenté le des comportements à
risque par exemple est extrême a mis
vraiment le sommeil on peut pas le dire
assez la sélection d'essentiel durant
toute l'enfance et l'adolescence je vous
remettre le jeu vous remettre le tableau
là parce que c'est moi je regarde ça je
me dis mon dieu j'ai pas été un bon papa
parfois parce que mes enfants n'ont pas
dormi
autant d'heures 3 5 ans 6 10 à 13 heures
quand même énorme 6 à 12 ans 9 à 12
heures 13 à 18 ans faut pas oublier les
adolescents lada on ne parle pas que du
prix même aussi de l'adolescence je
boudreau il paraît que les récréations
que le ministre robert ghiz a demandé
d'inclure ce qu'ils étaient on a tous
applaudi une bonne idée il me semble que
c'est un venu quand même compliqué
l'heure du début des classes
effectivement dans certaines écoles qui
avaient décidé d'annuler la la
récréation de l'après midi parce que la
période de temps pour le l'enseignement
d'après midi étaient plus courtes ont dû
rajouter une réac les récréations de 20
minutes ce qui a occasionné comme
conséquence que la classe a commencé
plus tôt il ya aussi un autre phénomène
qui ne faut jamais perdre de vue c'est
qu'est ce qui se passe au milieu des
services de garde scolaire
je peux vous dire que dans beaucoup
d'écoles les services de garde ou sites
auxquels 6h45 mêmes 6h30 le matin parce
que des enfants sont déposées par leurs
parents au service de garde
alors il ya des enfants qui passent
énormément d'heures à l'intérieur des
quatre murs de l'école et ça c'est ce
phénomène qui est de plus en plus
fréquent qu'on constate de plus en plus
dans nos écoles primaires mais justement
je regarde pas ce que j'ai reçu il ya
une seconde
un coréen d'une madame roy qui me dit
oui c'est bien beau ce que vous dites
ce roi mais les parents vont continuer à
les envoyer au service de garde très
très tôt qu'ils ne vont être plus
longtemps à l'école sans être encadrés
par leurs enseignants vous êtes un peu
d'accord que samsung ou trop basses et
le phénomène que l'on constate sur le
terrain
évidemment si on retarde le début des
classes
ces enfants là vont probablement passer
encore plus de temps aux services de
garde donc il peut être une période de
deux heures le matin et si cette période
qui se rallongent aussi dans
l'après-midi au secondaire si on
commence plus tard ce qui est tout à
fait possible c'est pas quelque chose
d'impossible mais si on commence plus
tard on enlève à plusieurs élèves la
possibilité de fréquenter le
parascolaire
comme on le sait le parascolaire c'est
une nouvelle priorité gouvernementale il
va y avoir un développement accru du
paraphe de l'offre parascolaires dans
les écoles secondaires
alors évidemment il faut pas que les
classes finissent trop tard pour que les
jeunes puissent fréquenter par ajouté
donc je vais je reviens vous docteur
chadia près mais je résume ce que vous
dites monsieur boudreau vite on n'a pas
besoin d'une nouvelle réglementation
parce que on a trouvé quand même un
point d'équilibré le matin là
effectivement c'est toujours ça s'est
ouvert un point d'équilibré pour les bus
et les besoins des enfants d'abord il ya
aussi les besoins des parents on peut
pas faire fi du boisé des parents et
aussi la volonté des équipes écoles
parce que vous savez dans une autre
commission scolaire les écoles primaires
ont deux plages horaires il y en a une
plus tôt une plus tard et chaque fois qu
une plage horaire plutôt se libère les
écoles se bousculent pour pouvoir la
prendre
alors vous voyez c'est pas une question
très très simple de réponse
malheureusement magique à cette question
là ouais parce que docteur chad il
faudrait cesser ces multi tâche de faire
intervenir parce que les parents
effectivement dans beaucoup de clubs
vont en mènent les enfants très tôt ou
services de garde fous drake de
meilleurs transports en commun il
faudrait en rythme de vie en général
plus apaisée moins de circulation
pas de bouchons sur l'a15 là ça dépasse
vos compétences dr chen
effectivement on glisse de côme en glace
est certain que le système faire en
sorte que c'est pas toujours possible de
maximiser les heures de sommeil ou les
heures où effectivement les jeunes
peuvent être dans l'eure
des questions qui sont très complexes
qui vont au delà du cas de la médecine
très bien mon à noter en tout cas qu'on
croyait important de le faire
l'importance du chomeil tentait d'avoir
la meilleure route possible pour les
plus petits et pour les plus vieux ne
pas oublier que à moyen et à long terme
ça peut être drôle une nuit blanche deux
là des fois mais non on a besoin de
dormir pour être équilibré
merci à vous deux magazines au revoir au
revoir